Jiro Horikoshi was the most brilliant Japanese
aeronautic engineer of his time.
He grew up dreaming of bringing Japan into
an age where people could travel the world
in airplanes.
But he was born in a time when his country
was at war, and the only use for his talent
was to make bombers during World War II.
Horikoshi designed the famous A6M Zero Bomber.
This was considered to be the most successful
dog fighter of its time, and the plane would
eventually become associated with the infamous
Kamikazes.
On today’s Biographics, we have the story
of Jiro Horikoshi’s life, and the impact
his creation had on the world.
Head in the Clouds
Before we get started with today’s story,
we’re going to do something a bit different.
I want you to think for a moment about the
dream you had as a child.
Maybe you wanted to be an astronaut, artist,
or teacher.
This passion we all have when we are young
often dies off as we get older, because the
powers-at-be try to place obstacles in our
way.
For Jiro Horikoshi, the thing that always
filled him with childhood wonder was airplanes.
Born in 1903, Japan was slowly transitioning
from living an ancient lifestyle to adopting
modern technology that had been created in
Europe.
In Jiro’s home town of Fujioka in Gunma
Prefecture, people were still traveling on
dirt roads, and using oxen to plow their fields.
But Jiro looked up to the sky.
Sometimes, if he was very lucky, he could
see an airplane flying overhead.
Even if he couldn’t touch or see it, he
knew that there was a whole world out there
him to explore off the islands of Japan.
The idea that a man could fly seemed like
magic, and he wanted to become a pilot.
However, he was nearsighted from a young age,
and began wearing glasses.
He could not become a pilot because of his
eyesight, but he learned that it was still
possible to design planes, even if he could
never fly one.
The only way Jiro could learn more about airplanes
was to find European and American magazines
on the subject.
Japanese translations did not exist, so he
would have to get a dictionary and go through
the articles word-by-word in order to understand
them.
This was the first generation of people in
the world to experience electricity, and Japan
was still running by candlelight.
Jiro Horikoshi’s mind was already traveling
the world and learning to respect other cultures.
At the time, one of the most respected aeronautical
engineers in the world was an Italian man
named Giovanni Battista Caproni.
He was famous for constantly pushing the envelope
on innovation, and testing the limits of what
was possible in airplane design.
A silent film was circulated around the world
showing Caproni’s ridiculous attempt at
trying to make a “flying boat”, which
was a passenger plane with multiple layers
of wings.
Even the mere concept of a passenger plane
was incredible at the time, because small
aircraft could only carry one or two people.
The idea that something so heavy could fly
through the air with dozens of people inside
seemed impossible.
In today’s world, we truly do take it for
granted how easy it is for an entire family
to go on holiday.
Jiro Horikoshi would have seen Caproni’s
attempts to make magnificent planes.
Caproni was truly a legend among aspiring
engineers, and young Jiro began sketching
his childish designs of the planes in his
imagination.
Living the Dream
Lucky for Jiro Horikoshi, Tokyo University
opened up a brand new aviation program at
their school.
He traveled to the big city to join a group
of young men who were just as eager to learn
about engineering as he was.
Finally, Jiro had a group of friends who were
just as passionate about planes, and most
of them would go on to become his future colleagues.
In Tokyo, people were finally traveling by
trains and tram cars, and the city was a blend
of traditional Japanese style and European
influences.
For a boy who grew up in the middle of nowhere,
this would have been truly spectacular.
He began taking classes in Calculus and Physics,
and learned how to elevate his sketches for
airplane design blueprints.
For a while, things were looking up, and he
was on the path to making his dream a reality.
But on September 1, 1923, Jiro was 20-years
old when Tokyo was struck with The Great Kanto
Earthquake.
It only took years for Japan to finally install
their modern innovations, but only a few seconds
for it all to crumble around them.
The trains and trams were derailed from their
tracks, and buildings were destroyed.
The earthquake happened at noon, so almost
everyone in the city was cooking their lunch
over an open flame all at the exact same time.
This caused a series of firestorms like nothing
we have ever seen in modern times.
Thousands of people attempted to take shelter
in the army clothing depot, only for them
to become sitting ducks in the pathway of
a fire tornado that killed 38,000 people.
Since the earthquake destroyed the water mains,
it took two days to put out the flames.
Clouds of black smoke filled the skies of
Japan, and it could be seen from miles away.
The earthquake was followed by a tsunami,
and several after-shocks.
Thousands of people were dead, and nearly
2 million became homeless.
Just like that, the Japanese people were back
to living in the dark ages.
What followed was a time of great paranoia.
Racist sentiments against Koreans and Chinese
people lead to rumors that their limited resources
were being poisoned, which lead to massacres
of anyone who was non-Japanese.
Without proper housing or health care, disease
began to spread, as well.
When people are struggling to have their basic
needs met, there is no room for higher education
or innovation.
There would be no industrial revolution for
Jiro Horikoshi and the other young engineers.
During the fire, students at Tokyo University
scrambled to save their precious aeronautical
engineering books from the flames.
Most of the students had to bury their friends
and family.
For a long time, no one was worrying about
studying math and science.
It was purely about surviving to live another
day.
It would take years for the city to fully
recover from the natural disaster.
Many of the original class either died, or
had to give up their dreams in order to work.
Jiro was fortunate enough to have family back
in Fujioka, so they didn’t lose everything
they owned.
When the school reopened, he was able to return
to Tokyo and complete his degree.
Working for Mitsubishi
After graduating from Tokyo University, Jiro
Horikoshi got his first engineering job working
for Mitsubishi when he was 24 years old.
Today, you might recognize the name for being
a famous car manufacturer.
Turns out they have been around since 1870.
At the time, the corporation was called Mitsubishi
Internal Combustion Engine Company Limited.
Their main competition was the Nakajima Aircraft
Company, and the two were rivals in the fight
to win contracts from the Imperial Navy.
Unlike the audacious designs of Giovanni Capronni,
no one in Japan was thinking about developing
passenger planes to take people on holiday.
Obviously, the Navy’s main concern was making
sure Imperial Japan could be just as strong,
if not stronger than their enemies.
For his first assignment, Jiro Horikoshi was
asked to work on an existing team that was
tasked with rebuilding The Mitsubishi 1MF9,
which had been nicknamed “The Falcon”.
It had been commissioned by the Imperial Japanese
Navy.
A crowd of people stood to watch the Falcon
take its first flight, only to witness it
completely fall apart after the pilot attempted
to reach maximum speeds.
Engineering companies like Mitsubishi needed
government contracts in order to survive.
The higher-ups in the Imperial Japanese Navy
told all of the engineers that they needed
faster planes in their ongoing conflict with
China during The Second Sino-Japanese War,
which overlapped with World War II.
If they did not satisfy the Imperial Navy,
Jiro and his friends would all be out of a
job, and their nation may lose the war with
China.
He worked day and night doing maths and sketching
out designs.
Most of the airplanes created by Japanese
engineers were copies of ones that had already
existed elsewhere.
Creating a new plane design that has never
existed before is incredibly difficult and
expensive to make.
After years of trial and error, Jiro finally
created a blueprint of a completely innovative
plane that was worthy of production when he
was 29 years old.
This was the Mitsubishi 1MF10, and it went
in development from 1932 to 1933.
It was a monoplane, which means that it only
had one wing instead of two.
However, after two failed tests, it was clear
that more adjustments had to be made in his
calculations.
Two years later, in 1935, Jiro created the
A5M, and it became the world’s first carrier
monoplane.
It was revolutionary for the time.
However, his innovation was ignored outside
of Japan.
In an issue of Flying & Popular Aviation magazine,
one article said, “Japan’s military planes
are so poor in comparison with other powers
… They have not yet gotten beyond merely
imitating what others have done.
Someday, perhaps, the Japanese will have accumulated
enough experience in a mechanical way to catch
up, but that day will not come soon.”
Actually, that day came much sooner than anyone
expected.
By 1940, Jiro began working on the design
of the next model, the A6M.
It was dubbed the “model number 00”, or
simply, the “Zero Bomber”.
It reached speeds of 500/km per hour, and
it was equipped with two 7.7 mm machine guns,
as well as two 20 mm cannons.
It could fly faster than any American plane,
and it suddenly put Japan at a technological
advantage over the Allies.
Pearl Harbor, and World War II
When the Japanese Imperial Navy saw the demonstration
of the speed and agility of the zero bombers,
they were singing high praises for Mitsubishi’s
work, and Jiro’s genius mind.
In China, these Zero Bombers were able to
completely dominate their enemy’s outdated
biplanes.
They were absolutely no match for Japan.
However, none of the Mitsubishi engineers
knew about the planned attack on America.
We all know what happens next.
The United States finally decided to enter
the conflict of World War II.
Just like Icarus, the Japanese Empire flew
far too close to the sun, and its resources
were stretched too thin, but these Zero Bombers
gave the Emperor a sense of new-found power.
For so long, the Allies had underestimated
Japan.
This Zero Bomber took everyone by surprise.
In fact, even Allied Intelligence operatives
had ignored any information regarding the
creation of Jiro Horikoshi’s new airplanes,
because they simply could not believe that
little old Japan was capable of developing
such an advanced bomber, especially when their
aeronautic industry was still so young.
Mitsubishi continued to pump out more and
more Zero bombers for the Imperial Navy, because
they were the only thing helping them stay
ahead of the Americans.
For a while, the US was truly terrified of
the speeds, and couldn’t keep up.
Eventually, the US navy recovered a fully
intact Zero Bomber, and they were able to
examine Jiro’s design and isolate its weaknesses.
They realized that the metal on the plane
was so thin, all it took was just a few shots
to the fuel tank, and it would explode.
Even though it could reach high speeds, it
became more difficult to maneuver and dodge
quickly when it was going too fast.
The Americans finally figured out how to take
down this nearly-unstoppable plane.
Because of this, Japan was losing their best
pilots, and they were forced to send men who
had little-to-no experience.
Eventually, the Americans could easily take
down the Zero Bombers in a matter of minutes,
and there was no time to create an even better
plane to replace it.
The only maneuver that gave Japan any hope
was the “Kamikaze”, which was when young
pilots were instructed to commit suicide by
flying directly into the American ships at
high speeds.
In anti-Japanese propaganda films, they claimed
that these men were so brainwashed by their
idolization of the Emperor, that they were
terrorist who were willing to go on a suicide
mission.
These rumors only fueled this idea that Japanese
people were all crazy, and needed to be stopped
at all costs.
According to one of the Kamikaze pilots who
actually survived, Saburo Sakai, none of those
men were brainwashed, and they weren’t trying
to kill themselves on behalf of the emperor.
They were desperately trying to protect the
people they loved, because they felt that
maybe their own death would help keep others
alive.
Sakai said, “Even if you don't tell him
to crash into something, putting a kid with
only about 20 hours flight time into a plane
and telling him to take on U.S. pilots is
just as much a suicidal tactic as being a
kamikaze.
But let me tell you, all that stuff you read
about dying for the emperor?
that's all crap.
They were thinking about their mother and
their family, just like anybody else.”
In reality, “Kamikaze” was never part
of Jiro Horikoshi’s plan.
He had actually designed these planes to last
for years, so that they could be re-used again
and again.
In fact, he even incorporated a flotation
device to release on impact, which ensured
that the plane would not sink after crashing
into the ocean.
He did everything possible to ensure the safety
of the pilots.
The idea was to make a plane that was so incredibly
fast, the enemy could not keep up, and they
could get in and out before putting themselves
in any unnecessary danger.
Just like with everything else, it was the
military’s decision to push men to suicide,
not his.
Jiro later wrote in his diary how horrified
he was by the whole situation.
“When we awoke on the morning of December
8, 1941, we found ourselves — without any
foreknowledge — to be embroiled in war...
Since then, the majority of us who had truly
understood the awesome industrial strength
of the United States never really believed
that Japan would win this war.
We were convinced that surely our government
had in mind some diplomatic measures which
would bring the conflict to a halt before
the situation became catastrophic for Japan.
But now, bereft of any strong government move
to seek a diplomatic way out, we are being
driven to doom.
Japan is being destroyed.
I cannot do [anything] other but to blame
the military hierarchy and the blind politicians
in power for dragging Japan into this hellish
cauldron of defeat.”
If the war wasn’t bad enough already, there
was yet another natural disaster.
In 1944, a major earthquake forced Mitsubishi
to halt their productions of Zero Bombers,
which put Japan at an even greater disadvantage
against the Allies.
Many of the buildings of the factory were
destroyed.
The engineers were relocated to a school building
while the factory was repaired.
Jiro Horikoshi was growing more and more depressed
and anxious about the fact that his planes
were causing so much destruction, and that
he was indirectly involved with the destruction
of the Japanese Empire.
He fell ill with pleurisy, and this forced
him to take time off of work.
That same year, Tokyo and Nagoya were being
bombed by the Americans.
Jiro was too sick to evacuate.
So he sent his five children, brother-in-law,
and his elderly mother to live in his family
home in Gunma.
Since it was in such a remote farming community,
there was far less danger there.
His wife stayed in Nagoya.
She refused to leave his side, and nursed
him back to health.
When he finally recovered and returned to
work, he saw the damage that had been done
to the city in his absence.
He wrote, “For the first time, I really
saw the effects of the incendiary raids on
Nagoya.
The city is a wasteland, charred and unspeakably
desolate.
My former factory is a ghostly, steel-ribbed
wreck, shattered by bombs and torn apart by
the dispersal crews.
It is hard to believe that all this is true.
I knew that soon I would be well.
Strangely, though, I had little desire to
return to work.
The impression of the shattered city and the
wrecked factories will not leave me.”
After spending only a week back at work, Jiro
Horikoshi realized that he truly could not
take it anymore.
He didn’t want to participate in engineering
weapons of war.
His wife accompanied him back to Gunma, where
he could live far away from the violence.
Even then, he could still hear the distant
sound of far-off-bombs being dropped on Japanese
cities.
The End of the Empire
In 1945, Tokyo was firebombed, and the Americans
killed between 80,000 to 130,000 people.
The Japanese were convinced even more than
ever that the sacrifice of a few men in order
to save thousands was completely necessary.
A 22-year old pilot named Kiyoshi Ogawa wrote
a letter to his mother after he found out
that he had been assigned a Kamikaze mission.
He wrote, “Looking back, when I think of
your raising me in your arms for more than
twenty years, I am filled with a sense of
gratitude.
I truly believe that no one else has lived
a happier life than me.
I am resolved to repay your kindness...I always
and forever will be living near you.”
Together with Seizō Yasunori, they flew their
Zero bombers directly into an American aircraft
carrier USS Bunker Hill, killing and wounding
hundreds of men.
Even though the deaths in Pearl Harbor and
USS Bunker Hill was a drop in the bucket compared
to the damage that the Americans had done
to Tokyo, the US continued to dehumanized
Japanese people to the point where it suddenly
became justifiable to drop the atomic bombs
on Hiroshima and Nagasaki in 1945, killing
an additional 129,000 to 226,000 people.
Mitsubishi manufactured a total of 10,400
Zero Bombers, and by the end of the war, they
were all destroyed.
Thousands of men were killed in their prime
because of the greed of a few leaders in power.
Jiro Horikoshi had to live the rest of his
life knowing that he was responsible for making
this plane that lead to so many deaths.
In a different time and place, his mind could
have been used for greater things.
Legacy
After Japan was occupied by the Allies, Mitsubishi
was forced to disband its operations in 1947.
Jiro Horikoshi stopped designing planes, and
became a professor at the Tokyo University
Institute of Space and Aeronautics.
Finally, he was able to teach his passion
to younger men who were growing up in a time
of peace.
Even though they lost the war, Jiro Horikoshi
proved to the world that Japanese people truly
could invent new and innovative technology,
just like the western world.
He lived to see Japan develop into the industrialized
society that he had wanted for so long.
In the 1970’s, he finally achieved his dream
of boarding a trans-continental passenger
plane from Tokyo to New York City.
He lived to be 78 years old, and died of pneumonia
in 1982.
Now that the nation was entering a time of
peace, Japan could finally enter their technological
renaissance.
Today, when we think of the places in the
world that have the most advanced technological
breakthroughs in science and robotics, they
one of the first places we think of.
In 2013, the Oscar-winning Japanese director
Hayao Miyazaki premiered an animated film
about Jiro Horikoshi’s life called The Wind
Rises.
This was the last movie Miyazaki made after
announcing his retirement, so it became Japan’s
highest grossing film of that year.
There is also a documentary of the behind-the-scenes
making of the movie, called The Kingdom of
Dreams and Madness.
Hayao Miyazaki wasn’t just the artistic
director.
He also wrote the screenplay.
While he could find all of the facts about
the sequence of events Jiro Horikoshi’s
life, there was little known about his relationships,
or his personality.
Hayao Miyazaki’s father, Katsuji, was also
an aeronautical engineer.
By being born just a few years later, Katsuji
Miyazaki was spared the fate of having his
designs used as weapons of war.
In the moments where Jiro’s personal life
was a mystery, Miyazaki filled in the gaps
with the memories of his father.
He presents the idea that when two people
share the same dream, they are connected in
a way that transcends time and space.
No matter where or when you were born, they
can always understand one another’s passion.
While accepting an award for the film on Horikoshi’s
life, Miyazaki said that he was incredibly
privileged to have had a 50-year career during
a time of peace, because it meant that he
have the luxury to focus on making beautiful
things.
In the end, one can see Jiro Horikoshi’s
legacy, and believe that he is responsible
for thousands of deaths.
Or, they can choose to see the young boy who
had the passion for airplanes, only for the
forces of evil to turn something beautiful
into a vehicle of destruction.